it is going to be another windy day for
us you see these two flags right here on
tuesday 2 22. they're blowing in the
wind already and the palm trees as well
southerly breezes are already starting
to pick up temperatures back where they
belong in the normal 40s even some
chilly or upper 30's up there at
centennial hills harry reid
international the airport's starting to
feel some winds up to about 20 miles an
hour and not every neighborhood is
feeling the breezes yet but as we get
through the day we will get those
southwest winds back later this morning
we'll feel those winds and by the
afternoon back to 40 to 50 mile an hour
winds and that's going to put dust in
the air
out on the roads it's going to be a
little bit dangerous trash out there on
the road so please be careful turn your
sprinklers off today don't waste any
water if today is your watering day
chance of rain later this afternoon into
tonight and it could be turning to snow
as we've got more cold air coming into
southern nevada and we've got cooler
days in the next few days with
afternoons dropping the low 50s and
mornings near freezing mount charleston
looking for maybe some snow this
afternoon into tonight and some of
that's going to be blowing snow too with
winds 45 miles an hour or so high today
of only 32 degrees here's the system you
can see the spin right here it's over
northern california northern nevada and
it's going to drop right into our area
later today these are all winter storm
watches and advisories as well as wind
advisories these areas of blue
all for southern nevada into southeast
california those start at nine o'clock
this morning and go until eight o'clock
there's going to be blowing dust winds
40 50 miles an hour again pretty much
like yesterday and these winter weather
advisories for northwest arizona could
see three to five inches of snow on
interstate 40. that's east of kingman in
kingman could see one to three inches
lincoln county is looking for snow and
up at lee canyon we could see maybe up
to three inches of snow as well we need
the snow desperately and we need the
rain i don't think we're going to get a
lot but i think we might get some of
those showers around 58 for the high
today that's down from yesterday's mid
60s chance of rain tonight and with the
rush of cold air that's where it may
turn into snow or at least a mix into
tomorrow morning up until about 9 a.m so
may see it on the bushes the grass the
trees we don't expect it to stick to the
roads but we will see maybe some more
sunshine by the afternoon look at those
chilly days and cold cold nights near
freezing all the way up until the
weekend and then back to 60's even some
70's to welcome march